khi mình trình thành trình, trù tịch trông quốc tập cật bình đã có cuộc đệ đạm lên thứ 2,
với tổng thủ Mỹ đồ năng tròng kệ từ khi ông tròm đắt cử tổng thống nhận kì 2 của người Mỹ.
Tại của để đạm, trù tịch trung quốc tập cật bình hẳn định.
Mắc kinh vào Washington có thể đạt được thành công và tình vựu trung
mà là lệ xong cả 2 nước vào thế giới,
trong thôi phản đối có bịnh pháp áp thẻ đơn phương từ Washington.
Ông tập cũng kêu gọi Mỹ đạm bảo một môi trường kinh rang tôn bằng kỡ mở,
và không phần biệt đối xử đối với các công ty của Trung Quốc
FFMN trong một tên bố đang trên nền tạm mạ sơ hội chú xấu
Tổng thống Mỹ đôn ra trong khẳng định
Cui để đàn với chủ tịch Trung Quốc đã đã đến trên về nhiều vấn đề rất quan trong
trong độ có thương mại
Mà tuyệt phét tán nhiên, sự cần thiết phải thêm rất cuộc sống đồ tình ạ của quay nà
Cũng như việc thông qua thảo thật lên quan tự, FMN tích tóc
Tổng thống trong trò biết sẽ gặp chủ tịch Trung Quốc tập cận mình
Mình lê hôm gặp gạo dễ đàn hợp tắc kinh tề cho ở thái bình dường à bách tại Hàn Quốc
Dự kiền dễn ra sau hơn một tháng nữa
Nông thời ổng cũng tiếp lộ kế hoạch sẽ thăm chủ Quốc vào đầu năm 2020